I can't do it either I'm saying I'm
telling you I strongly agree with you
this feels like a like a marital
argument see
oh for crying out loud can we move on
[Music]
so do you guys think you're going to
agree on stuff disagree I think we're
gonna agree on all that yeah
was that a test
American chocolate is the worst three
two one wait there's a difference what
he said American chocolate would you
like to try British chocolate yeah I
mean is it like a different formula oh
but you just said American chocolate
okay that leaves the rest of the
universe like Mars chocolate okay it
leaves everything this is why Willy
Wonka is like three hours because it's
hard to open up your chocolate I need a
golden ticket it's it's you like milk
chocolate are you a milk chocolate fan
I'm more of a dark chocolate oh
it feels like you actually use real milk
I feel like just with that alone I'm
gonna answer it for you yeah right yeah
yeah do you like American chocolate I
think there's some nice artisanal um
um
um chocolate I thought it was like the
swish I thought they LED I thought they
led the charge with the chocolate it
smells so nice it's just the sound of it
reminds me of Charlie the Chocolate
Factory and he goes
Grandpa
because that actor always did that I was
working
Grandpa
got a golden ticket
and then he's asleep and he's like what
Charlie and then he swings his legs out
of the bed
and then they go and send the adventure
oh so good
can we keep this yeah
I'm so sorry
he's good chocolate yeah
hats are better than dogs three two one
cats you're a cat person I don't think
anything is better than anything else
but I do think that I relate maybe more
with cats than dogs but I do love dogs
very very deeply but I'm allergic to
cats and it might be
that's why I think they are better
because I've never really spent been
able to spend a whole lot of time with a
cat
I share your allergy and but I have five
dogs and they're them they're amazing
fine
dogs are just like it's easy to love
them you know what I mean but there's so
many beautiful things about cats I mean
they're aesthetically yeah okay yeah you
know what I'm just I just feel like I
need to you're going that far I gotta go
over here yeah no and I'm gonna stay I'm
going over here now why do you not like
cats Gabriel I just really I mean aside
from being allergic like eyes close up
like
you've gone one of those those cafes
where you're in there eating I've been
to a cafe with goats yeah goats yeah
cats everywhere no I can't do it either
I'm saying I'm telling you I strongly
agree with you this feels like a like a
marital argument oh see
okay that's a little better thank you so
much yeah yeah I got it oh God no don't
do that yeah no it's okay if we got it
white enough so much you got it wet
enough left it really shot up there
hold on I'm sorry just give me a second
I'm trying to keep things sanitary
around here
oh sorry I'm just kidding okay the
British accent is the sexiest in the
world three two one
agnostic here right I'm gonna go here
I'm gonna go here
it's pretty sexy though
what accents do you think oh okay nicer
than others
I'm gonna say something right now I'm
gonna go with personality over accent
sorry to be uh that is you know what I
mean
credit score correct okay respect that
too that's about it I think about it
credit score and and personality yeah
helpful actually that's pretty good
criteria but I like a Chicago oh really
yeah a nice just a nicer voice you know
like a nice Timbre doesn't necessarily
mean the twang is not necessary the
Timbre is nice
[Laughter]
I'll take it
you never know
I would last longer in the world than
the person opposite me three two one
last longer I did not survive
in survival strongly like yeah I
strongly no no yeah I strongly disagree
you would definitely last longer than I
would last
you may look like you're you're 25 30
but you are actually 50. so and I look
the age I am so I I would say to you I
would say to you that that just on that
criteria alone outside of your credit
score and your personality I'm gonna say
that you would probably survive I think
that's very kind and you are surviving
more than I'm surviving so particularly
at this game if this is a criteria for
survival I'm so yeah I feel I failed at
this game from the jump and I need to
really try to come back because you're
coming back okay cool okay good
pineapple on Pizza is disgusting three
two one
oh I like variation you know what I mean
don't get me wrong
if you have not switched this interview
off by now there's something wrong with
you but what I will say is that
occasionally I have this desire for a
bit of sweet and salty and I do think
that it's nice when it's baked pineapple
well I heard pineapple helps with with
some of that oh I strongly agree
I love pizza but I don't like pineapple
on my pizza I like meat
thank you
I am excellent at Impressions three two
one
that is solid who'd you imitate I
imitate my Aunt Joanne go go go go go go
go she's a conspiracy theorist and she's
always angry nothing is ever right
she's
this is Aunt Joanne winning the lottery
let me tell you about the moon
because I don't tell you about the taxes
I had to get you you ain't watching
and that is Andrew
soccer is more entertaining than
basketball
ah why is that I mean I played both but
I mean she has a affiliation that I
don't think she's allowed to yeah
I think they're both both beautiful
Sports both very very fun to watch yeah
if you don't understand the game of
soccer I feel like it feels boring to a
lot of Americans because there's not as
much scoring I guess so you can't really
see the players up close like
as well as you can like with basketball
I guess
okay we're into the minutia yeah okay I
understand are you guys gonna be
watching the World Cup yes I'm going to
be watching the World Cup yes but that's
the other thing is like time zones like
a whole other issue with with that so
the person opposite me is a joy to work
with oh
we didn't work together though
but like for real I really am surprised
at how incredible she is and I don't
mean that in that really annoying actor
way your irreverence and humor is a
beautiful thing to sit next to so thanks
yeah
well it's just true
if sweet is true then man would it be as
not sweet world I guess I don't know I
liked where you were headed
that's where he lost me I lost myself
too I literally don't know where I am or
what I'm doing what is this game there's
written on a table and we're moving cups
back and forth thank you so much yeah
thank you you're welcome yeah no thank
you you do have a son yeah thank you
oh thanks guys
sounds like plan
enjoy time good
interviews now
I like American football I just don't
understand why it's called football
because they don't use their feet yeah
it should be causingly different maybe
throw ball whatever you want to call it
but you don't kick it you do kick it
yeah but once yeah